en vídeos anteriores sobre comunicación
celular hablamos de la idea de que si
tenemos una célula allí y digamos que
tiene algún tipo de receptor no tiene
que estar justo en la membrana celular
pero lo pondré ahí mientras tanto y se
puede unir a algunos ligandos que cuando
el ligando se enlaza al receptor y
generalmente el ligando es en particular
para el receptor y viceversa puede dar
pie a toda una cascada de eventos y en
particular una vez que se enlaza solo
déjame dibujar el ligando enlazado al
receptor puedes tener una señal que le
diga a la célula que haga algo puede
decirle que puede activar algunos genes
puede cambiar el metabolismo de la
célula de alguna manera y esta señal que
va desde el receptor hacia el interior
de la célula y que hace que las células
se comporten de alguna manera es llamada
transducción de señal la llamamos
transducción
entonces transducción
señal
en el vídeo anterior fui poco precisa
acerca de esto tú podrías haber dicho
cómo es que la señal realmente entra en
la célula cómo es que se mueve a través
de la célula cómo hace que sucedan cosas
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo y no
entraré en todos los detalles pero te
voy a dar una reseña de cómo la
transducción puede realmente ocurrir y
ojalá también te dé idea de qué tan
complejos son en realidad los organismos
biológicos incluyéndonos a ti ya mí e
incluso a cada una de nuestras células
entonces esta vía que estamos viendo
aquí puedes ver que hay varias vías que
trabajan juntas y se traslapan en
términos de las enzimas y las proteínas
que están involucradas está como lo dice
en el diagrama es la vía de la mapp
quinasa y si se preguntan qué significa
map quinasa muchas veces la gente solo
dirá
o me aplica que significa proteína
kinasa activada por mitógenos del
ingreso
michael gale activated protein sciences
y ustedes dirán que significa nitrógeno
tú
no
se refiere a cosas que provocan que las
células sufran mitosis que realmente
entren en mitosis que empiecen a
replicarse a sí mismas ahora que es
activado por mitógenos esta vía va a ser
activada por un mito gen o proteínas
quinasas activadas por mitógenos bueno
una proteína kinasa hemos visto muchas
quinasas en múltiples ocasiones tienen
que ver en muchos muchos muchos
mecanismos biológicos este es un término
general para las enzimas que ayudan a
tomar un fosfato de mayor energía o un
enlace de mayor energía o un fosfato
parte de un atp o un gtp y lo
transportan a distintas moléculas y
mientras lo transportan son capaces de
aprovechar esa energía para facilitar
algún tipo de mecanismo así que como
dije no voy a entrar en todos los
detalles aquí en realidad es bastante
complejo pero quiero darle un poco de
sentido en realidad vamos a hablar de
algunas proteínas y de algunas enzimas
que son
muy importantes en la investigación
biológica moderna
entonces lo que tenemos justo aquí y voy
a empezar con esta molécula justo aquí
está ese ligando es el link canto
y va a ser liberado por otra parte del
sistema biológico por otra célula y está
eje efe que significa factor de
crecimiento epidérmico del inglés
epidermal growth factor el premio nobel
de 1986 de medicina fue otorgado en
realidad por el descubrimiento del eje f
factor de crecimiento epidérmico ahora
esto va a ser el ligando esto es
básicamente lo que se une al receptor va
a provocar que la transducción de la
señal entre en la célula si puedes
imaginarte va a unirse a este miembro
receptor
efe fr que significa receptor del factor
de crecimiento epidérmico del ingles
epidermal growth factor receptor
receptor eje efe y es parte de este
complejo de proteína y una vez que se
une ayuda a que se active el r&s justo
aquí
el área s una vez más todos estos
nombres tienen historias interesantes
asociadas a cada uno de ellos este
significa sarcoma de rata
sar
coma
rata
los sarcomas son cánceres en ciertos
tejidos del cuerpo
las proteínas rush fueron descubiertas
por primera vez asociadas a ciertos
cánceres de rata ya que ratas que tenían
ciertos sarcomas tenían ciertas
mutaciones en los genes que producen las
proteínas rush debido a estas mutaciones
la proteína rush y las enzimas asociadas
a ella estaban en su modo activo y
debido a que estaban en su modo activo
este mecanismo estaba de alguna manera
súper activo y las señales para
detenerse no estaban ocurriendo
realmente entonces podemos imaginar el
mecanismo justo aquí que es de
diferenciación celular y si este
mecanismo procede eventualmente va a
decirle al adn algunas partes del adn
especialmente a las porciones del adn
que están involucradas con la
replicación del mismo en la división
celular en la mitosis van a volverse
locas
y esto es justamente lo que sucede en el
cáncer así que esta vía es una vía muy
importante en el cáncer
puedes ver justo aquí de verdad puedes
ver la vía de la map quinasa comúnmente
llamada fue llamada originalmente rk que
significa quinasa reguladas por señales
extracelulares del inglés extracelular
saint andrew gilbert & sciences
pero esta es una vía realmente
importante para investigadores del
cáncer y buscan tenazmente diferentes
tipos de drogas diferentes tipos de
moléculas que pueden debilitar este tipo
de vía entonces todo el punto de este
vídeo y una vez más no voy a entrar en
todos los detalles de la vía de la map
quinasa es darte una idea de qué tan
complicada es la transducción tienes
esta cascada de esta señal que es en
realidad estos grupos de fosfato
originalmente transferidos de gtp yendo
al área s lo que mantiene esta cascada
abajo hasta que se comunique al adn o se
empiecen a activar mecanismos donde
empezará a replicarse el adn
entonces la célula va a proliferar por
sí misma y diferenciarse esto debe pasar
en prácticamente todas las células de
nuestro cuerpo pero hay todo tipo de
factores que impiden que se vuelva loca
pero si tienes una mutación en algo como
el gen rush que codifica la proteína
rush entonces puedes acabar con una
célula cancerígena espero que esto te
haya dado un mejor panorama de cómo
ocurre la transducción realmente